I remember when I was about 14 my father
came alone he says here's a book you
need to read it was Marx's Das Kapital I
said dad have you read it he said no so
why should I read it you need to know
what other people think and it's about
your own faith journey up to this point
you now obviously speak to many people
all over the world about Christianity
but but where did it all begin to you
began for me and let me say as well her
delighted I am to be back in Costa Mesa
and I've enjoyed in the past some
marvelous shows with Justin and I'm just
fascinated by what's going to happen in
the conversation tonight but I grew up
in north of the island which isn't
always the best start to discuss
religion because it was a divided
community and there was a lot of
terrorism that was connected in a very
complex way to Christianity of both
versions Protestant and Catholic but the
important thing was that my parents were
very unusual for that kind of cultural
context they were Christian convinced
Christians but they weren't sectarian
and that was very unusual my father had
a small business we lived in a small
town 15,000 or so and he tried to employ
people from both sides of the community
nowhere did he do that I once asked him
I said dad it's so risky and he was
bombed for doing this my brother nearly
lost his life and he said look he said I
believe that every person whatever they
believe is of infinite value because
they're made in the image of God going
back to the Hebrew Scriptures and
therefore I will employ across the
community and that has stuck with me and
it's been very important
when you're discussing as I often do
with people that do not share my
worldview that always comes to my mind
here's a person in front of me and it
relates to what you were saying about
freedom I would connect with freedom
values that here's something outside of
my parents that gave every human being
dignity and value that was point number
one the second thing was that they
allowed me to think now northern islands
often associative or religious bigotry
extreme fundamentalism all this kind of
thing and my parents were not highly
educated but they really gave me space
so my first encounter with Christianity
was not mind closing it was mind
expanding and I remember when I was
about 13 my father came alone he says
here's a book you need to read it was
Marx's Das Kapital I said dad have you
read it he said no so why should I read
it you need to know what other people
think I never forget that it was said a
compass bearing the third point is there
Christianity was credible morally
credible they actually lived what they
believed so in that sense I had a hugely
privileged background that didn't
compress me into a narrow-minded bigoted
person and it was noticeable when I went
to Cambridge in 1962 not 1862 I know
anything but when I went to Cambridge in
1962 many of my contemporaries saw
Meredith the moment they got out of the
country that was the end of any
Christianity because they'd never made
it their own they'd never thought about
it but I'd been encouraged to think
about it and that sort of set the the
compass bearings there's one further
point of really shaped my life I was
challenged in Cambridge very early on by
student at table night
and he said asked do you believe in God
and then he said oh sorry sorry sorry I
shouldn't have asked you that you're
Irish all you Irish believe in God and
you fight about it I'd heard that many
times but somehow it was different and I
thought gosh yes you know I've never
really met atheist you know in Ireland
people divided the Protestant atheist
and Catholic eight they're not really
really thin sighs so I thought what I'm
going to do is to start today and
befriend people to friend them that's
important that do not share my worldview
and I'd spent my whole life doing it so
that's not really assess the the scene I
think so
neech famously declared God is dead now
he may have been a bit premature in that
but maybe he's finally you know his
thoughts are coming true in 21st century
West because we are living in an
increasingly post Christian age people
say increasingly the number of people
who take the census box that says none
no religious affiliation is going up and
so on I mean you're you're engaging with
this kind of demographic all the time on
your show Dave what's your feeling do
you do you feel like people are
genuinely less religious now to what
extent are that some of those friends
that you made early on in your show
people like Sam Harris and another
well-known atheist responsible for
people moving away from you know the
religious bearings that they once had so
obviously I don't want to speak for for
Sam or any of those guys what I have
found in the conversations that I've had
with non-believers and with believers is
that at a micro level you can be a
non-believer and be absolutely moral and
decent and no good and a productive
member of society and all of those
things as I believe those couple people
that I mentioned are what I think is
becoming the problem and I think this
was really where Jordan Pederson hit on
something
is that society's can't organize around
that that it can sort of work for a
while and there's you know most of the
things that I believe in and I you know
I I talk about the individual all the
time and why I believe that classical
liberalism is the best sort of framework
for a political system that we should
have they almost can't exist without
that underlying bedrock and so your
question sort of gets to what I was
saying earlier which is that the reason
that the secular world feels so out of
control right now I mean just just
yesterday I'm sure some of you guys saw
the CNN did this quality Town Hall last
night and it was like you know everyone
has to mention their gender pronouns and
you have to admit that there are more
than two genders and all of these things
that you know these conversations are
not being had there are settled science
debates that went on for a long time
that we know we know what facts are and
yet we find because this has now become
untethered to anything other than how
you feel that now everything is up for
grabs and that's why it sort of feels
like that there's something sort of
godless happening here or something like
that now trust me that is a that is a
hard thing for someone like me to say
you know as someone that really might my
beliefs really are rooted in the
Enlightenment and Enlightenment thinkers
and this is a real debate amongst people
who talk about the Enlightenment could
they have done it
could they have reformed religions and
burst liberalism in a positive way
forward without some religious belief
behind it I don't know the answer to
that exactly I don't know that we'll
ever really know the answer to that but
I would say that the reason I first said
that I'm happy to be here with you guys
is that in the last year where now I've
virtually only get invited to events by
conservative groups or you know
libertarian groups for sure but groups
on the right let's say but I often get
invited to churches I often get invited
to places of faith now I know we can go
through a litany of political
disagreements that we may or may not
have
and I absolutely know that everyone in
this room would be happy to do that
and there would be nobody fighting there
would be nobody screaming we could
explore those ideas as far as we can and
then we would put it down in front and
either agree to disagree or maybe maybe
we'd move each other one way or another
and that would be wonderful and I don't
think that's a coincidence I don't think
it's a coincidence that you guys here
and the generally believers right now
are more tolerant they are it's just the
reality the people yeah give yourselves
a round of applause that's I mean that
really is true who are the most
intolerant people in society right now
it's the people that are constantly
telling you how tolerant they are that's
the that's the irony it's the people
that tell you you're a bunch of racists
and bigots and homophobes in the rest of
it and and that's the real bizarre flip
that we have happening in society and I
think that is linked to either however
you want to phrase it either a
post-christian world or a post
judeo-christian world or or a postmodern
world however you wanted to find that I
mean to what extent do you agree with
Dave's analysis thereof what's going on
especially I suppose of that academic
level and in terms of the kind of
conversations now that you are and
aren't allowed to have almost I think
it's a pretty accurate analysis if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about
spirituality instead of non-stop yelling
check out our spirituality playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist there all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell